hello and welcome to this video playing
white dragon from Sweden yeah this is
getting more and more popular than push
up at five yeah I'm just copying cards
in here did play provoking age six and
then Bishop d3 this can be helpful
sometimes at age six move ok I just
castle him before now or do we first I
go before can also Oh interesting like
usually takes unknown efore in this kind
of structure we'll see what is what is
up to okay 11 idea is to go e five then
I deform
yeah but that helps them a lot with this
sim and c5 push ok I think now I'll go
for it trying to do something on the
Kings side we have got more space
to go over them
my bishop here on c1 doesn't really have
them kill ya clear way to go it's a
little bit a little bit tricky
looks okay for black the two lights they
are really strong try to regroup here on
the King side but that is feeling a
little bit artificial
yeah my bishop who don't see one looks
yeah but I could never develop it I had
no option down yeah I know I can
actually develop it one down there
should be three yes you will go night at
five anyway
okay let's do this
yeah nice playing that quite well I
think trading my dangerous pieces sound
III and so on and I don't don't know if
I have something really against the king
there are no real threat he has many
moves maybe even the cheeky 96 h 4 which
is that's really a bit too cheeky but
maybe he can still do that can also just
take u 3m
and now it's taking a long time I mean
it played almost instantly reform check
okay
right so that's well it's okay it's
really just okay hmm maybe go for that
pin I have to doubt save my position
look strange Queen takes Queen B to C 5
that looks like it shouldn't work but I
don't see at the moment why it doesn't
so I'll go for it
Queen B to C 5 I already hope that works
but
yeah still don't think I'm threatening
much they're on the King side
those whose night there's always some
kind of danger but I don't see a clear
threat IAM and potentially not have six
or nine th six but both is not not
working really not okay so let's check
this can i take c 5 now I don't see why
I cannot so I think I'll grab it okay
let's think briefly if some night have
six stuff works here really shouldn't
but so I'll take that I don't see a DC
line where this wouldn't work now this
Knight f6 now night h6 and Queen to e7
check he has to go to h eight and
Queenie seven I love this hangs was
check but they're still g3 check
OOP check I didn't didn't expect that
Queenie seven was my idea I had to move
the king I really don't know what
happened on the 27 check
check
check checkmate I was a very lucky
winner he basically outplayed me out of
the opening hmm Jim that wasn't any good
it wasn't any good for me here with c5
and this whole staff was probably far
too ambitious he had looked looked weird
dr. B it ok hear the engine gives Bishop
takes h6 for me as a move but I didn't
see that coming interesting check what
happens if he takes a direct line I'd
obsessed King age 8 and Queen h5 ok that
looks kind of dangerous actually winning
according to the end you're interesting
ok well I went here Knight a5 not g4
check and to coop ta that all looked
very and very sound solid everything and
now it took here here to grab this
really very curious hero check this this
computer doesn't give a win for black
but this seems to be good for him and
Queen deform check
oh and check check bloggers defending
this young check what what did we have
we had this check yeah now I thought
King edge it creamy 7 that was what i
was thinking and I was just hoping
hoping it works like somewhere here i
was thinking i can take actually it
takes I'm sorry takes tapes this is what
I what I was seeing and thought that
might be okay for me Jackie chick I
didn't calculate further but I thought
that he I might have have enough somehow
because it's difficult for him to
coordinate this engine gives equal then
he's talking to a giant frog yeah I was
very lucky win okay thanks for watching